good morning this is a Lydia company
from bt and I'm talking here from the
West in Cape Town question is how can we
translate vision into action for Africa
we all have a great vision for Africa I
believe strongly believe that Africa has
shifted to new era around growth and
hopefully of open economic development
all right now how to transform that into
real action I believe is that Africa
needs stronger infrastructure from the
technology in order to connect all of
the country together and work as one and
in order to connect Africa to the rest
of the world this has started but this
needs to continue we already have a
number of subsea cables connected
several countries including South Africa
he's now is to be further developed and
ensuring that technology is a strong
support to the economic development in
Africa let's go for actions it's my time
for